previously in part two mr. Samuel please
welcome to the property
this power has completely just failed
so it's been a couple of months now
since the crash course and oh my
goodness no it went brilliantly but you
know what for me it's not about how well
did the event go was the event smooth
did people enjoy it that's that's part
of it but over the last two months I've
been absolutely bombarded with messages
and success stories from people who've
implemented what they've learned and
that for me is what it's all about in
fact just yesterday I had a guy message
me his name's Keegan and he misses me
out the blue on Facebook I didn't
remember him you know there's 200 people
at the crash course and I was like who's
this guy and he said hey Samuel just so
you know I live in London after going on
the crash course I bought a house
exactly based on what we learned using
the template and everything and I'm
going to pick up the keys today all
right it was yesterday and he said do
you want to come and meet the estate
agent and get the keys together and go
look at the house now I wouldn't
normally do that but I just get so
excited seeing in hearing people
implement what they're doing from the
crash course I actually did so yesterday
I drove down to Darby and I saw the
house and it was a house it was worth
130,000 pounds and he negotiated using a
negotiation tactic tactics he bought it
for a 102 500 that's like twenty seven
and a half thousand discount and he's
getting a thousand pounds profit per
month from the house
so just incredible meeting him and he's
one of many so how did it go absolutely
incredible I'm really proud of the
students and I'm really pleased with
myself and it just amazed that I when
I've just come out of a private
boardroom meeting with Lord Allen sugar
it was really really good there was five
businesses in the room and we were sat
around a table for just over an hour and
he is so sharp
he's so sharp my experience with Lord
Sugar was absolutely amazing I wasn't
sure if it would be like it is on the
apprentice you know where he's really
brutal and hardcore it was exactly
he really is I told him all about my
business he grilled me on it after
grilling me on it and me giving him all
the ounces he came to the conclusion
that yes your business model is great
the way you invest is good
so right now we are off to pick up some
baby things
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I'm really excited about the next
two or three weeks it's like the end of
a the end of a marathon run isn't it
we're gonna try film as much as we can
as well yeah we'll be vlogging
definitely in the hospital I really want
to remember this and be able to look
back oh my god IRA I was feeling like
this at that time and coming down every
every day really can't wait to see this
little wound was it just broken and now
we're gonna go to the hospital how you
feeling
oh she's just come out that just
happened to us like two minutes ago man
was coming down to the next hour with
the safe babies
joy
[Music]
oh my gosh labor was so hard but it was
just so intense the way a but Samuel was
so good at being my my look my coach in
the whole process he really did help me
he was my rock through it helping me
keep it together like sometimes I just
like break down and cry and be like wow
so hard I can't do this
he was like come on around it keep going
[Music]
we decided to call a ruby just because
we love the name and we'd love to think
of her as our precious jewel because
she's so precious to her so we just
thought it'd be fitting I when she was
born because most people said all you
might change your mind but it just felt
fitting doing it first the hair ruby joy
[Music]
ruby joy she's out joy she's just
everything to us I thought oh it's just
we just gonna have a baby in the house
but life will just continue on us we can
just watch a movie where we want to
watch a movie sometimes she doesn't
agree with me when she's sleeping we can
do but when she's up it's totally like
all eyes on her type thing and looking
after her person with the most energy
wins yeah yeah especially at night when
she just wants to play and it's like no
sleep time now she hasn't quite grasped
the idea of day and night yet which I
didn't really think about before she was
born I just thought she just go with the
flow of whatever we're doing I didn't
think it'd be so much us going with her
with her flow
[Music]
you
you
I remember when I was 14
me and my brother were with our
girlfriends at the time and we were on
our way home from a dinner and we
basically got attacked we got we got
ambushed by a gang and as a result with
that I spent three Angry years trying to
find the addresses and all the names and
stuff of the people that attacked me my
brother and I've still got you can
probably see the scar right now what I
left my hair short you can we got you
know bottled and beaten with bricks and
snickies there's a really bad attack so
I was really angry and it's one time no
word of a lie I'm 17 years old I'm lying
in my bed about to go to sleep and
people say to me man you a Christian so
how did you find how did you find God I
didn't find God God found with me but no
17 years old I'm lying in bed and you
know I don't push my beliefs on anyone
but I speak for what happened to me and
that was that God just showed up I just
felt I just felt the presence of God in
the room
and he spoke straight to my heart said
Samuel follow me oh and I'm thinking I'm
not I can't be a Christian I can't live
a life a godly life like I've seen other
people doing that's not that's not about
me I've got all these people that I hate
that I'm happy with that I need to get
revenge on first before I start making
any religious you know changes and but
this this this corn to my heart was so
strong and I remember the saying to God
I said gotta look I can't I can't live
like that I can't be a Christian I can't
be a godly person but if you want to
change me
I'll give you permission and as soon as
I said that since it - gotta give you
permission
my heart just changed and then went to
plug myself into a church and completely
turned my life around
and my church sent me off to Africa and
different stuff in India it was
incredible I've never looked back a few
most later
remember questioning governments thank
God have have you really changed me are
you really real or if I just turn over a
new leaf
you know it is really a big spiritual
encounter epiphany or is this just me
growing up and choosing to let things go
and what I was questioning God on this
I'm on the computer you know my my
laptop and I'm just and I don't even
know how happened but I just stumbled on
this social media website called bebo I
don't even think it exists anymore
I stumbled across this website and saw
one of the faces and the names of one of
the guys that had grasped me what I
clicked on him and all his friends and
all the faces the names the locations
friends our friends were just down front
of me and I'm gonna thinking this is
like cold this is what I've wanted for
us all these years but I wasn't angry at
than much in fact I just had nothing but
love and forgiveness as I saw the faces
I didn't want to get revenge on them I
just wanted them to come to church and
this I just felt that I just found God
saying to me this is my way of saying
yes
you've been changed I've changed you I'm
real so shut up move on never look back
if that if the experience have been
attacked
all those guys if that hadn't have
happened
I don't have really pushed me over the
edge
today I would probably be very different
it's funny how in fact jealous is
fifty-fifty it says what you meant for
evil God meant for good and it pushed me
to the point where I was so angry I was
so bitter I was so in living in fear and
living that I had to do something you
know so yeah and now anything that
happens to me that bad has not look good
I'm just challenged to have the same
mentality I just say look it's bad right
now
but it everybody happens for a reason
somehow so not only is it helped but
he's also giving me a new philosophy of
hope so it's definitely worked out for
good and I'm a different person because
of it
[Music]
so we were talking a lot about are we
going to carry on with the crash courses
and the training after we have Roubaix
because it will be difficult learnt it
will have it you know you you normally
get really involved with the crash
courses it takes so we're we carry on
and the interesting thing is right now I
guess you could say that we we're living
the dream you know we've got it made
we've got a beautiful baby girl we've
got beautiful home we we don't have to
work we've got really a really good team
and staff that worked so we could just
enjoy life blissful a continue with our
charity work and just you know live the
good life but we I don't know I mean the
John John Maxwell says that success is
about you significance is about others
and once you've tasted significance
success will never satisfy and I think
that we genuinely just love empowering
and helping and teaching and equipping
others to get out of their jobs to live
a good life whatever that looks like so
I personally can't I can't see us
stopping the training anytime soon can
you because we love it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you